come fare a tutti sono gabriele e
stasera vi parlerò di medical education
un settore che comprende la formazione
del personale sanitario sia prima che
dopo il conseguimento della laurea
non vi preoccupate se molti di voi non
l'avranno mai sentita nominare però
stasera cercherà di chiarirvi un pò le
cose e vi spiegherà soprattutto come la
tecnologia può integrarsi in maniera
benevola in questo settore ad oggi
questi servizi di formazione vengono
offerti da vari enti e istituzioni
troviamo in primis le università le
scuole di alta formazione che sono delle
vere e proprie fucine di specialisti
anche società scientifiche e gli ordini
professionali come quello dei medici
degli infermieri si stanno attivando in
questo senso e infine stanno emergendo
soggetti ed enti privati associazioni
studentesche e dispositivi di
dispositivi medicali
ma a chi si rivolgono tutti questi
servizi di formazione sicuramente tra i
primi destinatari troviamo gli studenti
da sempre bramanti di una conoscenza
meno nozionistica e più interessati alla
pratica clinica e alla realtà medica
in realtà anche i giovani professionisti
e coloro che escono dall'università non
è che se la passino meglio nonostante il
numero chiuso abbiamo in italia abbiamo
medici infermieri odontoiatri che non
riescono acquisire durante il loro
percorso di studi delle competenze
pratiche sufficienti a permettergli di
lavorare in di lavorare in autonomia e
paradossali lo so però è la realtà
potrà sembrare strano ma anche gli
specialisti coloro che già hanno una
carriera lavorativa avviata hanno sempre
necessità di aggiornarsi e imparare
nuove tecniche perché si sa in questo
lavoro non si smette mai di studiare
infine troviamo operatori del 118 e o ss
vi starete chiedendo quali sono le
ragioni che mi hanno spinto a
interessarmi a questo settore
sicuramente influito il mio background
universitario e i docenti della nostra
università
ma soprattutto è la
azione che nutro per lo sviluppo delle
nuove tecnologie in particolare nel
campo della didattica
ad oggi il mercato del medico education
si compone di tre macroaree che
sfruttano metodologie didattiche
differenti eppure perfettamente
integrate
abbiamo le lezioni frontali che sono le
classiche lezioni universitarie tenute
da docenti o esperti si stanno diciamo
evolvendo verso l'apprendimento ibrido
il blended learning che utilizza
dispositivi quali smartphone e tablet
oppure piattaforme virtuali di e
learning per trasmettere contenuti o
verificare le competenze
infine troviamo i laboratori virtuali
questi sono il vero carburante
dell'innovazione che investirà questo
settore nei prossimi anni utilizzano
tecnologie quali realtà virtuale in
realtà aumentata che permettono al
discente una vastità un'offerta
formativa un portfolio di esperienze e
conoscenze virtualmente senza limiti
a questo punto dobbiamo capire qual è la
situazione della formazione medica in
italia proprio per questo motivo tra
giugno e luglio dello scorso anno ho
lanciato un sondaggio in alcuni gruppi
facebook costituiti principalmente da
studenti e giovani professionisti tutti
under 30 hanno risposto più di 4000
persone
essa sera vorrei analizzare con voi
alcuni dei risultati
vi devo dire che la stratificazione del
campione cioè la localizzazione
geografica delle persone che hanno
risposto rispecchia è abbastanza
uniforme in tutta italia quindi
rispecchia adeguatamente qual è la
situazione del nostro paese non esistono
[ __ ] e polentoni in questo caso siamo
tutti nella stessa barca si vede subito
dal grafico a sinistra che solamente
poco più del 40 per cento delle
università italiane hanno adottato
programmi educativi 2.0
mentre la restante parte o in dubbio o
non lo sa
o no attualmente i sistemi di educazione
di insegnamento più utilizzati restano
le lezioni frontali e i classici
tirocini superando il 90 per cento delle
risposte solamente tre ragazzi su dieci
affermano di poter avere accesso a
lezioni interattive oa laboratori
anatomici mentre meno del 10 per cento
ai laboratori visto a questo punto ho
chiesto anche come valutavano gli
studenti ei giovani professionisti
italiani
la formazione pratica e teorica ricevuta
durante gli anni di università
sicuramente a conferma che la formazione
teorica italiana e una delle migliori
d'europa
vediamo che il 68 per cento la definisce
buona il 17 per cento ottima e il 13
sufficiente completamente diverso è il
discorso per quanto riguarda la
formazione pratica vedete che il più del
60 per cento
la definisce insufficiente e questo è il
vero problema ma anche quasi il 25 per
cento un ragazzo su quattro ha definito
la definisce appena sufficiente e solo
il 12 per cento buona
a questo punto ovviamente i ragazzi
hanno dichiarato di dover sopperire a
queste carenze in qualche modo il 60 per
cento di loro dice di sopperire a questo
se inseguendo frequentando dei corsi
pratici addizionali quelli che chiamiamo
formazione addizionale e il 30 per cento
di loro addirittura dice di aver seguito
seminari teorici e tutto questo ha un
costo che ho chiesto di stimare circa il
25 in 7 per cento quindi uno su quattro
spende meno di 100 euro durante la sua
carriera universitaria
1 se la somma sempre uno su quattro
spende tra il 100 e 500 euro e
addirittura quasi il 10 per cento spende
500 euro
tutto questo per garantirsi una
formazione pratica adeguata che gli
permetta di lavorare in autonomia
e veniamo al punto
sembra che il settore del medical
education nei prossimi anni sarà proprio
rivoluzionato da la realtà aumentata è
la realtà virtuale
io personalmente sostengo fermamente
l'utilizzo della realtà aumentata e
medicina e vi spiegherò brevemente
perché in primis non è totalmente
immersiva
questo significa che l'utilizzatore non
viene escluso dalla realtà semplicemente
vengono aggiunte nuove informazioni e
queste informazioni ovviamente possono
dare un vantaggio perché non perdendo la
realtà
noi abbiamo semplicemente delle dei pop
up
immaginatevi come se fossero dei pop up
che ci dicono cosa fare cos'è quella
cosa e via dicendo
inoltre non si perdono i feedback non si
non si perdono i sensi umani
voi avete visto a volte il capitano i
bambini che toccano le cose si si
scottano per esempio perché noi da
bambini abbiamo un modo di interagire
con la realtà per conoscere per
apprendere che quello di toccare e up
e proprio il feedback tattile che non
deve essere perso e che la realtà
aumentata ci permette di utilizzare
infine la realtà aumentata
non è computer based o meglio non è
completamente computer based
questo significa che i costi per
l'integrazione e lo sviluppo sono
sicuramente inferiori perché non
necessita a differenza della realtà
virtuale di potenti unità di calcolo o
di schede grafiche la realtà aumentata
oggi esiste e la utilizziamo abbastanza
quotidianamente e già implementata sui
nostri smartphone e ci permette di fare
alcune cose come per esempio misurare un
oggetto grazie alla fotocamera del
nostro cellulare visionare un'anteprima
di come un mobile starebbe nel nostro
salotto oppure se volete giocare ai
pokémon
i vantaggi della realtà aumentata
dell'utilizzo di queste tecnologie
nell'ambito della medical education gli
ori assunti in questa slide in sei punti
in primis la durevolezza perché a
differenza dei supporti dei manichini e
dei supporti atomici attualmente
utilizzati che inevitabilmente vanno
incontro a deterioramento e usura questi
su questi dispositivi software non sono
soggetti a queste problematiche
inoltre sono versatili con un solo
dispositivo possiamo avviare infinite
simulazioni e essere sempre avere
contenuti sempre aggiornati su qualsiasi
argomento sono portati lì perché
purtroppo è finita l'era di grandi tommy
enciclopedici da trasportare
adesso la cultura può essere accessibile
a tutti in qualsiasi momento e non più
ristretta in determinati luoghi
inoltre lo studente avrà sempre il
totale controllo del proprio studio e lo
potrà adattare ai suoi tempi e al suo
metodo di studio e questa è
un'innovazione per noi
infine l'utilizzo dei supporti sintetici
e della realtà aumentata permette di
ridurre o meglio diciamo cioè assenza
completa di rischio biologico e di
crudeltà verso gli animali perché oggi
noi abbiamo le cavie i tessuti biologici
che possono trasmettere patologie e
quindi devono essere maneggiati e
smaltiti adeguatamente in tutto inoltre
è tutto più etico e sostenibile
a questo punto dobbiamo capire qual è
l'impatto che queste tecnologie possono
avere nel settore io le ho riassunto
sotto quattro aspetti e in primis
dobbiamo parlare delle tecnologie
la domanda che dobbiamo porci è quanto
le tecnologie attualmente disponibili
possono essere impiegate per utilizzare
questo settore
questo perché noi in tasca abbiamo degli
strumenti potentissimi i nostri
smartphone
che utilizziamo solo per il 2 per cento
tra facebook
instagram whatsapp una delle più grandi
sfide nel prossimo futuro sarà proprio
questa capire come utilizzare ciò che
già usiamo per comunicare o divertirci
al fine di imparare costi perché
ovviamente tutte queste tecnologie tutte
le tecnologie in generale quando vengono
lanciate sul mercato hanno un costo
un costo che è alto e su questo è vero
soprattutto nel settore medico
quindi il nostro obiettivo deve essere
creare qualcosa di accessibile a tutti
non solo agli studenti e ai giovani
professionisti ma soprattutto alle
università perché è proprio a loro che
dobbiamo rivolgerci
se vogliamo che queste possano garantire
una didattica veramente innovativa a
tutti la domanda che più spesso mi viene
fatta è ma tutto questo non porterà a
disumanizzare l'apprendimento e quindi a
this adattare disabituare i giovani al
contatto umano a queste persone bisogna
rispondere che si avrà sempre bisogno
dei docenti e dei tutor qualificati
semplicemente queste figure cambieranno
il loro ruolo andranno ad agevolare gli
studenti con difficoltà oppure
semplicemente a verificare le competenze
acquisite
infine il risultato sui pazienti perché
si sa in medicina alla pratica rende
perfetti e ad oggi una delle più
difficili sfide che la medicina si trova
che la didattica in medicina si trova ad
affrontare è proprio la disponibilità di
soggetti e patologie sulla quale
esercitarsi senza causare danno né a se
stessi e né agli altri
in quest'ottica il l'utilizzo di tessuti
sintetici e di tecnologie digitali
permette di rispondere adeguatamente a
questa esigenza senza dimenticare la
prima regola di ciascun medico
primum non nocere
immaginate un futuro dove è possibile
apprendere qualsiasi argomento
semplicemente indossando un visore un
futuro dove poter potremmo praticare
qualsiasi procedura chirurgica qualsiasi
sempre su tessuti sintetici senza che
questi possano causare sofferenza
qualcuno quindi senza avere il timore di
danneggiare qualcuno
immaginate un futuro dove i pazienti
ricoverati possano sentirsi come a casa
loro
beh fa sorridere però questo futuro ce
l'abbiamo già in tasca grazie
[Applauso]